michael is in the lobby of ramsey
solutions hey Michael how are you man
good Dave how are you better than I
deserve
welcome are you from Durham North
Carolina cool good to have you man
thanks
so you're here to do your debt-free
screen I am how much did you pay off
about fifty four thousand dollars great
and how long did that take about 30
months way to go and your income
household income during that time range
started at 45 and ended up now making 70
way to go how did you get that much of a
raise in 30 months
um just switched a couple jobs got a
couple promotions and landed where I am
now good for you what do you do for a
living I do a corporate accounting for a
manufacturing company Wow so it you know
a lot of people get raises while they're
working their way out of that why do you
think that is what else you just start
thinking about it yeah well I think it's
just the the focus you have you know you
have a goal and you have this this
intense focus and that somehow it just
kind of makes you work harder it just
really you know when you have a goal you
work harder and as a byproduct you you
get raises and promotions just because
you've put out more you're more
productive
yeah well that makes sense people notice
you and then the competitor will steal
you and yeah what and pay you more and
all that kind of stuff that makes sense
yeah yeah so just the income is part of
the equation it's half the equation
income versus outgo and so once you
start concentrating on that it calls you
to do what it takes to create that
income absolutely very interesting so
what kind of debt was your fifty four
thousand about twenty thousand with
student loans and thirty-four was cars
ah okay yeah what did you do did you
sell some cars or do you pay them all
off well I guess I paid them all off I
started with one car got into an
accident and so I thought I needed a two
year old BMW so I bought that of course
on debt and I borrowed about twenty
thousand for that car and then about a
year later I realized that was a mistake
so I traded car two swapped cars I got a
Honda Accord and I paid that one off but
then I fell off the bandwagon and
decided I needed a newer car so I got a
two-year-old mazdaspeed3
so that's what I'm driving right now and
I just paid for it about four months ago
ha
very good all right and that was the
last date your last car payment you ever
have I hope absolutely you're done I'm
sick of it so you're a car guy though
obviously I am yeah I love car cars
they're fun
so they'll kill you financially but yeah
I love them I've realized that yeah when
you take the hit on the depreciation and
yeah it's pretty serious it really is so
you're single yes
so what happened 30 months ago that put
you on this track to get out of debt and
get out of this card debt and out of
these student loan debt well I've
realized I needed to start saving for my
future you know someday I want to retire
and do things and I thought I want to do
and own a business perhaps and and so I
realized that this was a kind of
standing in the way you know that I
needed to I need to get serious and do
something about it because you know I
only have one life to live and why not
live at debt-free
a man well was there something that
happened one day that kind of gave you a
wake-up call or switch the you know flip
the switch where you went okay I got a
look at this it's a particular event do
you remember well I mean I listened to
you back then and you know I've got
introduced you back in 2012 I buy your
Total Money Makeover book and I was kind
of like Diddy bopping along for a year
and then you know the middle of 2013 I
like somehow a switch flipped and I was
like you know I need a I need to really
get serious about this so I started
making a goal to pay off my debt you
know that's the problem with listen to
this show I'll wear you down you keep
turning it on I'll eventually get
through to you so it wasn't a particular
moment it just kind of you worked your
way through it then you picked up the
book and started doing it right and then
I went through FPU in 2015 and I took it
actually I took it twice so I went
through the second time in 2016 this
year Lara sorry earlier this year watch
you go back through well I took my
girlfriend through but mainly I wanted
because I felt the bandwagon and I
bought that card oh so you were talking
along and then you got then you didn't
you bout you bumped into that car I
didn't catch that part I got a fever so
oh man yeah you had to go back to her
cuz you flunked yeah
how long so many times you and believe
it man I'm very very proud of you how
does it feel now that you got control it
feels like I'm walking on a cloud
seriously I mean just like having not
having any payments except for rent
it just feels I mean this isn't
unbelievable next time you see a really
really sweet car I mean sweet that you
don't have the money for how are you
gonna keep from buying it I just can
remember the pain that I went through to
pay my other cars off uh-huh good answer
okay
I think you might be telling the truth I
think you might I think you might have
done it you might actually be through it
I think it's one of the hardest things
for a car guy to stop buying cars on
that is it really it's tough I used to
back onto little things for the cars
like upgrade the cards you know like put
intakes and exhaust and stuff on and go
racing around with it on like autocross
courses and you know I'm kind of done
with that now I'm just coming you know
it's just a way I'd realize it's just a
waste of money it's just a car so even
though they're fun to drive it's just
the car at the end of the day mm-hmm
well you get enough money you can afford
to drive whatever you want drive if you
drive like no one else later you can
drive like no one else just like if you
live like no one else later you can live
and give like no one else so what advice
do you have to people who are trying to
get out of debt stick to a plan I think
that budget was the biggest thing that
helped me top you know created a path
for me to get out of debt also having
some accountability whether you know my
girlfriend kept me accountable the last
year or so and just having somebody to
talk to you about you know your
decisions because your decisions can
kill you like if you just happen to walk
into a car lot and buy cars that can
technically okay just like that like
that and they'll sell it to you sure
they will they have know it without
hesitation it make you think you're the
smartest guy on the planet when you're
buying it Wow well congratulations
Michael very proud of you you're a hero
man way to go well done well done you
took control of your life old are you 28
and you're completely debt-free and that
congratulations
you're gonna make it this is great all
right Michael from Durham North Carolina
a fifty four thousand dollars paid off
in 30 months making forty five to
seventy thousand a year count it down
let's hear a debt free scream alright
three two one oh this is how it's done
that I hear baby this is how it's done
man I love it
absolutely well done hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show and so you have to
break the cycle you have to flip this
thing on its head and make it behave
you've got to get so fired up and wired
up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind